la non extradition de julian assange
était une bonne nouvelle ça c'est la
grosse question oui je me réjouis
énormément de cette non extradition en
sachant qu' il y aura probablement un
appel et que donc ce n'est que là
n'était pas terminé et je parle de lutte
parce que je crois que cette victoire
elle est due aux très nombreux petits
comités de base je parle en belgique
d'un comité et à sang en france vous
avez viktor dedaj et le site le grand
soin et toute une série d'autres qui
sont mobiles se sont mobilisés et je
crois vraiment que cette victoire pour
julian assange
c'est une victoire populaire c'est une
victoire de mobilisation très large pour
le droit de savoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]